Speaker 1: also join the discussion with
more than close to 35000 actually of our
viewers and listeners on the David Pakman Show
subreddit. That's at David Pakman dot com slash
Reddit Reddit. Let's look at a few posts from
the subreddit. First, one from user Joey Death
says, Does Ukraine realize that a no fly zone
equals World War Three? There's really no way
to word this without throwing shade at the
Ukrainians, but I keep hearing Ukraine and
the Zelensky administration calling for a no
fly zone, as I'm sure many of you have as well.
There's obviously no happy ending in store
for Ukraine, but I do wonder if this is a
heat of the moment thing for them. Since the
no fly zone and other U.S. NATO's restrictions
can lead to World War three, am I just not
seeing it from their heated perspective? So it
it is both true that a no fly zone could
well be the trigger for World War three,
but you also are not seeing it from the Ukrainian
perspective. So let's think think through that.
Why would a no fly zone potentially mean World War
three? Well, the issue with the no fly zone is.
Announcing a no fly zone is just an announcement.
It doesn't necessarily mean anything,
but when you announce a no fly zone, you have to
enforce the no fly zone. And what that means is
shooting down planes if they violate the
no fly zone. And it leaves open the idea
that Russia could just violate the no
fly zone with with pilot human pilot
piloted planes or send drones to have them
deliberately shot down to then justify an
escalation. There's all sorts of different ways
in which the enforcement of the no fly zone could
indeed lead to World War Three. What you also have
to consider as many of our Reddit users made clear
from the perspective of the Ukrainians, they
are seeing total war from Russia, and they
recognize that even if they've been able to resist
certain advancements from Russia to some degree,
Russia's military is absolutely massive. And so
although the enforcement of the no fly zone could
lead to some deaths, my guess is the Ukrainian
calculation is it'll save a ton of people.
In other words, you shoot down a plane and it
lands and the plane crashing kills a few people.
But think about how many Ukrainians could be
killed if that plane is able to do bombing
sorties sorties in Ukraine. So I think that we
aren't seeing it from the Ukrainian perspective.
And there's also accuracy accuracy to
the no fly zone enforcement could be
World War three. As of right now, no no fly
zone has been put in place. User h.O.H. H
posted to the subreddit Is sexism unavoidable?
What if a female comedian delivered the baldness
joke at the Oscars? Would Will Smith has had
slapped her and then walked away to receive a
standing ovation within minutes? Yeah, I think
this is a fair point, and I think that it is
inevitable that the situation was seen the way it
was seen, to some degree because the joke was made
about a woman's hair and the
person telling the joke was male
and the person doing the slapping was also male.
Now, I don't know that it's sexism necessarily,
but I think that this post correctly identifies
that were it. You know, Whitney Cummings or Nikki
Glaser or whoever, whatever female comedian
telling that joke about Jada Pinkett Smith.
If Will Smith goes up and slaps
her the way he slapped Chris Rock.
He's certainly kicked out, I mean, I guess they
tried to kick him out and Will Smith just stayed
and nobody did anything about it. He certainly
kicked out, if not arrested. I think that's true.
I think also there's another aspect to this,
which is if the joke had been made about a
bald man, there likely never would have been
a slap anyway. I mean, I think there's no way
to remove gender dynamics from that situation.
That doesn't necessarily make it sexism
and everything that that connotes. But there's no
question that gender played a role in everybody's
reaction. Last post today from Early Gold, who
posted Please support the bonus show so we can get
better audio controls. Yeah, I'm going to play for
you. There have been some horrible audio issues
plaguing the live streams lately. Here's just a
little bit of a of of a reminder for those who
might have been hearing myself coming back. That's
weird. Are you guys hearing me twice every time?
You're not. Just wait for it.
OK, let's try now. OK, let's try
now. No, I still didn't, I'm still hearing myself.
Speaker 3: OK, OK, let's try now. No,
I still didn't. I'm still hearing myself.
OK, let's try now. No, I still didn't. I'm
still my son. OK, let me try now. I still do know.
Still hearing myself. OK, oh yes. Right now, can
I still do know? Still hearing my song?
I guess I should, you know. Anyway, I
Speaker 1: won't play you guys with the
entire thing, but that did go on for about
10 minutes. It's not. We don't need a donation
to fix that or anything. Some people thought,
David, you know, maybe we need to donate to
fix your audio. No, it was just user error.
That's all it was. But I think we very, very
soon are going to have the audio figured out
for the live streams. Join the discussion on the
subreddit at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit